today the Matt wall show the drag queen
groomers are only getting more Brazen as
footage emerges of an R-rated drag show
targeting babies and toddlers as I'll
explain today we need a federal
Nationwide ban on this evil it's the
only way also attorney general General
Garland gives an absurd excuse for why
he's failed to make any arrests of
anyone involved in attacking pro-life
pregnancy centers the Tennessee female
cop who had sex with five of her
co-workers now says that she was the
victim of grooming another inclusivity
Workshop tries to tackle the what is a
woman question and in our daily
cancellation many members of gen Z do
not know how to speak the English
language even though it's the only
language they know we'll talk about this
rather serious problem and much much
more today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
if you've ever landed on a website that
wasn't secure or didn't seem legitimate
because of spelling errors unfamiliar
colors or fonts or just gave you a bad
feeling this may be part of a Cyber
attack this tactic involves cyber
thieves installing malicious code on
your computer that sends you to bogus
websites where they can steal your
personal information it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every day
your personal information gets exposed
so often that it's dangerously easy for
a cyber criminal to steal your identity
but protecting your identity can be easy
with LifeLock by Norton LifeLock
detection alerts you to a potential
identity threats you may not be able to
spot on your own like loans taken out in
your name if you do become a victim of
identity threat a dedicated us-based
restoration specialist will work to fix
it nobody can prevent all identity theft
or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but it is easy to help
protect yourself with Lifelock Identity
Theft Protection Starts Here join now
and save up 25 off your first year at
lifelock.com Walsh that's lifelock.com
Welsh for 25 percent off
last week the Tennessee legislature
passed its Bill Banning drag shows for
children actually it bans all sexual
performances in front of children the
bill uses the phrase adult Cabaret and
drag is not especially singled out or
even specifically mentioned drag queens
have felt personally targeted simply
because they happen to be the only ones
who want to perform sexually for
children the law forbids anyone and
everyone from engaging in sexualized
displays in the site of minors we are
all equally restricted in that area now
in Tennessee but the difference is that
the rest of us have no desire to do such
a thing we are repulsed by the very
thought of it many drag queens
apparently do have this desire and so
they complain that they're being
especially oppressed by this prohibition
now the days since the Bill's passing
the media has published one sob story
after another telling us about the
horrible plight of Tennessee drag queens
who fear that they may never be able to
perform a striptease for elementary
schoolers ever again and that really
really uh is a tragic thing for them
Business Insider just published
interview with local drag queen Bella
dubal and this is the same man who as we
heard last week gave a speech at a
recent drag event threatening violence
and riots if the ban on child
sexualization is passed
um he uh you know insinuated that if
he's not able to uh sexually perform in
front of a child then he might start
smashing people with bricks that's how
important it is to him that he's able to
do this now that it is passed um even
though he was the one threatening
violence he now says that he fears for
his life here's The Insider report an
interview with Insider dubal called the
bill terrifying and said she's
personally afraid for her own safety
notice the female pronouns by the way
they were using for drag queens
who don't even say that they identify as
women
but are but are you know putting on a
character and so they're referring to
the character as if the character exists
in real life in the article
uh it's like if there was a if there was
an interview with Joaquin Phoenix and
the interviewer referred to him as the
Joker in the article
the bill specifies that a second offense
would be considered a classy felony
which carries a jail sentence of up to
six years
quote I could go to prison for six years
for appearing in a public Pride Parade
the ball said I'm scared that if I'm
wearing gender non-conforming clothing
in Kroger and someone has their kids and
they clutch them tight and call the cops
I could get arrested just for presenting
that way uh in my daily life
quote there has never there's never once
been a child who has been sexually
assaulted or harmed at a drag show or a
pride performance if there had been it
would be a poster image for their
campaign we would see it everywhere
now of course as we know these people
lie about everything all the time and
he's lying here the law would not result
in him getting carted away in handcuffs
if he cross-dressed at Kroger
as much as that thought might be
pleasing to some of us
um that's not what would actually happen
this law specifically Outlaws sexual
performances
so unless he's in the produce section
twerking on the avocados he probably
doesn't have much to worry about in that
regard as for the claim that no child
has ever been assaulted or harmed at a
drag show
what he means is that there's been
no video of a child being physically
molested by a drag queen on camera
during the performance
because anything outside of that
doesn't count as assault or harm
apparently according to him
which is an interesting claim coming
from a guy who would certainly insist
that grown adults are both assaulted and
harmed when someone say quote-unquote
misgenders them
words pronouns can be a form of assault
yet for a child there is by this man's
telling nothing he can say to them or do
in front of them that would count as
harmful
we see once again how the most fragile
adults who have ever who have ever
walked the face of the Earth okay the
people who collapse into tears and
scream genocide if you say words they
don't like these same adults seem to
have somehow an unshakable faith in the
ability of small children to endure and
process any image or idea or experience
the adult needs to be protected from
from pronouns that scare him the child
doesn't need to be protected from even
R-rated sex shows according to this guy
this is why these people see it they
want us to see it that way but it is of
course totally wrong
in fact there is video evidence of
children being harmed at drag shows
every single child who's ever attended
one has been harmed
they are all abuse victims this is
abusive inherently by its nature to
involve children in something like this
and the abusers are only becoming more
Brazen about it case in point
footage has gone viral this week of a
show called
Kaba Baba Rave now this is a as you
might pick up from the name a cabaret
rave
that is meant for babies
yes babies it is a touring show that
goes from place to place performing
sexual Cabaret for babies and toddlers
here's an article on the British website
called the mank advertising one of these
shows first from a few months ago
because this has been going on for a
while
quote a cabaret Rave sensory experience
especially for babies and toddlers is
coming to Manchester later this year and
tickets are now on sale
our city region may never be short of
unique events and interesting things to
be getting up to but kabba Baba Rave is
gearing up to be unlike anything else on
offer for little manx and their parents
as it's bringing the experience of a big
London night out to a popular social
club uh this October it's described as
being a little slice of Afternoon
Delight that provides show-stopping
Cabaret interspersed with baby sensory
moments
and if that all wasn't captivating
enough as it is each session ends in a
rave Kaba Baba Rave is hosted by Lizzie
and Gemma two performers turned moms who
were constantly looking to be
entertained whilst holding a baby in one
hand in a pint in another
yes baby sensory moments is the
euphemism that they're using here
and if you're hearing about all this and
you're thinking to yourself well wait a
minute no way this we must be missing
something there's just no way that this
can be what it sounds like I refuse to
believe that something like this exists
a cabaret Rave for babies
well the footage of one of these events
should wake you up to the horrifying
reality it is very real
um and as you can see as you put the
images up on the screen there are
parents sitting around with their babies
and toddlers
watching as men in bondage gear swing
around on ropes
there's another man in a in a wearing a
thong and nothing else and doing a
handstand and spreading his legs doing
all of this for babies and toddlers
there are half naked adults adults
twerking
this is a full-on R-rated sex show
targeted at children three and under
that's what it is and it's as I said
been going on for a while Kaba Baba Rave
has been hosting sold out shows for
months at least without anyone objecting
or at least without the sorts of people
who would object finding out about it
now that we have found out about it the
groomers behind Kaba Baba Rave have
locked everything down they've gone into
hiding basically at least uh you know in
in cyberspace
um the website has been taken down the
Instagram Facebook page all that has
been turned to private and this happened
the moment that
these images the footage
emerged on social media and people like
normal people saw this they shut
everything down
the organizers put out this statement
just to let our followers know we've
turned out we've turned our profile to
private for a while we've been subject
to a pretty horrific trolling attack and
it just keeps coming as mothers with
young Toddlers and one of us heavily
pregnant this has become more stressed
and we're able to deal with right now
these trolls specifically have a problem
with drag artists and non-binary
performers performing for children which
is exceptionally sad as those of us who
have been uh who have been who those who
have been to our event will know how
much joy love and happiness our shows
bring
oh they are the victims of course they
think what a surprise
now
why is this happening I mean what is the
motive motivation for the adults
involved
well there's a lot going on we can
assume that the performers are perverts
who get a sexual thrill out of exposing
themselves to children
the parents are sick twisted freaks who
signal their allegiance to the woke
religion by offering up their children
in this way uh making a sacrifice of
their children's innocence for some of
them it might also be um as well more of
a selfish disregard
um I mean it's selfish regard across the
board but they're also they're also
parents who who personally want to
attend these kinds of performances and
they bring their kids along because they
don't really care what effect it will
have on the kids
and then for All the Above
there's also the overarching intention
to desensitize and confuse children to
induct them into the less sexual
pathologies and obsessions from a very
young age to groom them in other words
so there are varied motivations for all
these adults but one thing that they
have in common
is that they should all be sitting in a
prison cell right now and we will know
that we have restored some semblance of
sanity and dignity in our culture when
but not until we start seeing Law
Enforcement Officers swarming these
kinds of events handcuffing every adult
in the room and frog marching them out
of the building and into a prison cell
okay you could take the drag perverts in
their thongs and just throw them right
into jail we'll see how um sexually
expressive they want to be in that
environment
and then you take the kids away from the
parents and you throw the parents into
jail right alongside them
that's how we have to respond
because these perverts are not going to
stop on their own
they will only get more brazen
we have to stop them aggressively
by force by law
and that's why we need every Republican
presidential candidate in 2024 to
promise a federal ban on these child
drag shows okay kids in Tennessee are
protected now
but all children deserve the same
protection
we cannot be satisfied with a few
legislative victories in a few States
those are very good those are good
things that's a step but it's only a
step in the process and just as the ban
on child gender transitions must go
Federal
so must the law against this kind of
degeneracy
the other side they're only getting more
bold
more Brazen more extreme
we have to meet them with that same
energy
an absolute zero tolerance policy for
groomers that's the only way forward
now let's get to our five headlines
attorney general mayor Garland testified
in front of a Judiciary Committee
yesterday
um and a couple clips that are worth
taking a look at here he is talking to
Senator Mike Lee about rather trying to
explain
his failure to prosecute any of the
people who have attacked pro-life
pregnancy centers okay no one has been
prosecuted for this
um even though it is a federal crime as
he acknowledges but let's uh watch him
try to uh explain his way out of this
there have been over 81 reported attacks
on pregnancy centers 130 attacks on
Catholic churches since the leak of the
Dobbs decision and only two individuals
have been charged so how do you explain
this disparity
uh by reference to anything other than
politicization of what's happening there
the face act applies equally to efforts
to damage blockade uh
um um clinics whether a pregnant uh
resource whether they are Pregnancy
Resource Center or whether they are an
abortion Center it applies equally in
both cases and we apply the law equally
I will say you're quite right there are
many more prosecutions with respect uh
to the blocking of the uh of the
abortion centers but that is generally
because they are those actions are taken
in uh with photography at the time
during the daylight and seeing the
person who did it is quite easy
the those who are attacking the
Pregnancy Resources centers which is a
hard thing to do are doing this at night
in the dark we have put full resources
on this we have uh asked put
rewards out for this the justice
department the FBI have made Outreach to
Catholic and other
organizations to ask for their help in
identifying the people who are doing
this we will prosecute every case
against a Pregnancy Resource Center that
we can make but these people who are
doing this are clever and are doing it
in secret and I'm convinced that the FBI
is trying to find them with urgency
this uh every time I see a video of this
guy just like almost any other
bureaucrat he is so aggressively
unimpressive I mean along with
everything along with being a leftist
stooge and all that kind of stuff uh is
just such a such an unimpressive man the
way he's like every the way that he sits
there and is well I uh I uh we we uh
it's a bat it's a it's a it's a we we uh
we uh it's not good that they do this we
uh we don't like it we wish that they
would not uh but they uh the people uh
who do this uh they do it at night and
we don't that's actually what is his
excuse for not Prosecuting the attacks
on probably fighting centers
is that they happen at night
and so we we can't see them they're
doing it at night we don't know who it
is they they it's how what are we
supposed to do they're criminal
masterminds and they've thought that
they could do this at night and they
won't be seen and there's nothing we can
do we can't get we can't get past that
barrier
well yes there it is then if you want to
commit a federal crime uh just do it at
night and uh the feds will say well
we're out of luck another we could do
now of course they have not prosecuted
any of these um any of these attacks on
probably pregnancy which have happened
all across the country
and there's actually a group you know
there's there's a group that has claimed
credit for this
like there's a a group a terrorist cell
that has claimed credit for this and
it's you know threatened to do it
carried it out
and we're supposed to believe the
federal government has their hands did
no way they can't figure it out no way
to crack the case
yeah well you're not going to crack the
case if you're not trying and they have
no interest in it
they have no interest in it because the
abortion industry owns
the federal government certainly owns
the Democrat Party abortion industry
owns the Democrat Party
and so the abortion industry will send
you know if you if you do anything to
interfere with their business then
they're going to have their goons in the
government come after you
um but attacks on pro-life pregnancy
centers they're obviously quite happy
about that
speaking of not charging people Garland
also hasn't charged anyone who quote
unquote protested outside of a supreme
court justices home during the you know
after the road decision and before it
even though that is a federal crime okay
to show up outside of a supreme court
Justice's home
and uh in in an obvious attempt to
intimidate them and to sway their
decision making
that is a crime and here Garland
admitted admits that it is a federal
crime listen
General Garland
is it a federal crime to protest outside
of a judge's home with the intent of
influencing that judge as to a pending
case uh the answer to that is yes but I
also want to at least respond to your
characterization of the department which
I vigorously disagree with
um so admits Instagram then he goes on
to
justify the lack of prosecution just as
he did in in a way that is uh not any
more persuasive than what you hear when
you heard in his attempts to justify the
lack of prosecution of people that have
been attacking pregnancy centers and
what he says is that well we sent uh you
know we try to protect the homes we send
Law Enforcement Officers out
yeah but you didn't arrest anybody
is the same is the same problem there
they're doing it at night
I mean he even says there are cops on
the scene he wants credit for that
it's what the cops are not able to see
the people because it's dark
no they choose not to make the arrests
because again they don't actually have
any problem with what these people are
doing
all right
here's um
a horrific story that we have to talk
about unfortunately Fox News article
St Louis Missouri police arrested a man
on Monday who was allegedly captured on
video executing a man in Broad Daylights
police told Fox News digital that
officers responded to a call for a
shooting just after 10 a.m on Monday
when they arrived they found a victim
lying on the sidewalk and suffering from
a wound to the Head preliminary
investigation found the victim and a
male suspect engaged in a fight at a
nearby Shell gas station just before the
shooting
but there might have been some sort of
fight before the shooting that wasn't
caught on video but this shooting did
not happen in the midst of a fight was
not a crime of passion sort of situation
in fact the victim was sitting on the
curb on the sidewalk just sitting there
while the guy the shooter was standing
behind him taking about 45 seconds to
get his gun loaded and then he just
executes him right there and we know
about that because this was all caught
on video and we have the video
um
we'll play at least up until the moment
when the shot is is fired it's not it's
not it's not graphic you know in that
sense but it is
extremely upsetting
um to see this but here's the video
that's
made the round it sounds like I said
that was a gunshot
yeah there it goes
no he just put a magazine in it he's
still trying to load it
all right so
there's a couple of things first this
obviously is what our cities have become
um
we're finding out more about the the
suspect hard even call him the suspect
he's on video doing this identified as
DeSean Thomas 23.
um
police said Thomas was in possession of
a firearm and shell case at the time of
his apprehension
circuit Attorney Kim Gardner's office
charged Thomas with first degree murder
and armed criminal action
um and more will come out about this
DeSean Thomas scumbag it's it's if this
already has if this hasn't been revealed
already it's almost certain that we're
going to find out that he's got a rap
she you know a mile long and has already
been arrested a bunch of other times
because this is this is what happens is
what our city has become you have these
um
these
soulless monsters who it's to call them
simply criminals doesn't quite capture
they are that but there's something even
deeper than that these are soulless
monsters simply do not
value human life at all what makes that
video one of the things that makes it so
disturbing is that it wasn't this this
was not like he was enraged it's like a
some sort of uh road rage type incident
where someone just loses it and kills
somebody as terrible as that is
this is just calm it was like there's no
reason to do it but I'm just killed him
for no reason just because
that's why I've been saying for a long
time that as much as we hear about the
alleged scourge of hate crimes and how
how terrible it is to have crimes that
are motivated by hate
I think crimes of indifference are even
worse
and also a much greater plague on our
culture and on our cities
many of the violent crimes that you see
they're not even motivated by hate or
anger necessarily they're motivated by
the fact that the people committing the
crimes have no they're totally empty
inside they have no they don't value
human life they don't care about human
life
and they commit these crimes
for the sake of it
you know there was another video that
went viral that I'm not going to play
for you uh last week it's like you know
all these videos end up kind of
uh jumbled together in your mind because
we see so many of them but in this video
and I forget which city it happened in
but it's a it's a video of a guy
robbing like a gas station and he shoots
the
um cat guy behind the cash register just
shoots him he's already got you know
he's already got what he wants what he
came for shoots him anyway
and then he's the the the the cashier's
lying there on the ground bleeding and
he comes back and and shoots him some
more no reason to do that at all
but decided to kill him for the sake of
it
so this is what's plaguing our city are
these crimes of indifference
but speaking of indifference
you know we talked a few days ago about
that uh terrible video of uh an elderly
man being mauled by pit bulls this is
also something that goes on for several
minutes and this is in the middle of a
residential neighborhood and there are
people around there's somebody filming
it people all around nobody steps up to
try to stop this steps up to try to uh
uh you know protect this this man save
him from this horrific fate they're all
watching and there's somebody filming it
and it's the same deal here
you've got people that are filming this
as it happens
and before it happens
nobody tries to intervene
and nobody even
yells to the guy that's sitting on the
curb and to say run away he's going to
shoot you
hey there's someone behind you loading a
gun run away
nobody does that
they they sit back and just film it
that totally detached as if they're
uh you know filming a nature documentary
or something like that and they're you
know filming a a lion hunting a gazelle
they the passive Observers
that's the approach they take to this
but these are human beings and they're
watching a violent crime about to be
about to play out and they don't do
anything to stop it
now as I said a few days ago I know that
we can't
it's not fair to expect people to act
heroically you you want people to act
aerobically you hope that they will but
you can't expect that of people that's
why we call it heroism it's above and
beyond what you would normally expect
and you also can't say for sure whether
you would act heroically in that case so
a heroic action would be somebody
running out there and tackling this guy
before he shoots his victim that would
be a heroic action
it would be heroic but also someone
could have easily done that because he
didn't even it took him 45 seconds to
get the gun loaded
but even so that's heroic
we can't we can't we can't condemn
people for necessarily for not doing
that even though we wish that they that
they would
we can't say for sure that we would do
that if we were in that position unless
we've been in that position before and
have acted that way
but how about something that wouldn't
even qualify as heroic but at least
shows concern like I said Yelling to the
guy
get up and run away
that doesn't even require heroism
that just requires you to care a little
bit about this person's life
instead they sit around and film it
so the indifference
you know this plague of indifference
that I'm talking about it's not just
among the violent criminals it's also
among the general population
who are perfectly fine to stand around
and watch these things happen as long as
they can get it on video
all right
here's another one of these that we
always enjoy yeah again has it
asiato
laoyin a black queer neurodivergent life
coach was invited to speak on
intersectionalism at Wheaton College and
struggled with Matt Walsh's what is a
woman question
saying Womanhood is a social construct
it's definitive based on time and
culture so it's another attempt we've
seen a few of these now these workshops
and inclusivity seminars at colleges
where this question where they they have
a chance to wrestle with this what is a
woman question
and uh here's the latest what is the
valid response to the question of what
is a woman
um Womanhood is a is a social construct
it's not there's it's definitive based
on time and culture so people always
argue like a Womanhood is not a social
construct but what Womanhood is based on
you know
our past versus now has changed versus
you know what Womanhood is for us versus
other cultures so
case in point the color blue wasn't
associated with men and so
in I think the 40s
um and Men wore pink
for a while as well and so the fact that
like it's just so fluid within history
and different cultures
is The Testament to the fact that it's a
social construct and being a social
construct means that it is very much
individualized that it's not stagnant
um so
I guess I would start there and also
that
like Womanhood can't even be defined
because gender is a social construct and
gender
currently is defined by white dominant
culture of the binary any binary in it
of self but especially gender is all
colonization like it's the Erasure of
everybody else like even sex is a
spectrum I'm like every there's very
little in human behavior that's
absolute or black and white no pun
intended
um
so why should that be limited you know
to everything else but gender and
sexuality and all the things so yeah
so yeah
that's basically the entire answer you
could cut everything else out so yeah
you know whatever
she has no answer obviously what she's
saying
just to be clear
um
well the color blue wasn't associated
with men until the 40s I don't know
where she's getting that from uh I I we
could just there's no reason to think
that's based on anything but our own
imagination well let's go with that for
a minute the color blue was began to be
associated with men in the 40s fine
whatever it doesn't matter
because what you're talking about there
are the things that we associate with
the sexes
so
you're making an argument that the
things Society Associates with the sexes
are a social conscious
so the associations are a social
construct
and to a certain extent
um
that's true
okay so for example the uh
fashion kind of clothing that men and
women wear in different cultures that's
going to change by culture
and as the people on this side love to
point out there are cultures where it's
considered masculine for men to wear
things that would appear to us to be
like skirts or dresses you know maybe in
another culture tribal culture of men
wear sort of robes and they wear kilts
you know in Scotland
um
even though it's not the same thing as a
skirt but that's fine that's a social
construct
the the fashion that we associate with
each sex
but the sex itself is not a social
construct
it can't be
because in order for these associations
to be drawn in the first place the thing
it's being associated to needs to exist
you can't even make the statement that
well the color blue is uh only
associated with men because of a social
contract you can't say that unless you
know what a man is to begin with
it's a it's a social construct that blue
is associated with men
okay but what is that associated with
who
what are those
so it's very easy to pick all this apart
but that's why they prefer to have these
converts they're going to talk about
this at all and engage with this
question at all they're going to do it
in their safe environment their safe
spaces because they don't want anyone to
uh
you know start to pull at any of these
threads that are very obvious and
hanging there to be pulled
what they want to be able to say is just
to throw the buzzwords out the buzz
phrases
social construct
and then move on and that's what they're
able to do there
another another quick thing here
Tennessee this is the headline for New
York Post
Tennessee sex cop Megan Hall claims she
was sexually groomed in new lawsuit
Tennessee sex cops
kind of sounds like a band name but in
this case uh the article is the
Tennessee Cop fired over her numerous
sexual ROMs with other officers claims
in a new federal lawsuit that superiors
in her Department sexually groomed her
for the risque escapades Megan Hall 26
who blamed a troubled marriage for her
Randy Affairs claimed she felt trapped
and exploited in the midst of the
all-male ranks of the LaVerne Police
Department according to her 51-page
federal complaint filed on Monday
the lawsuit says where Miss Hall sought
Role Models at her new job she instead
found Predators a place of offering
professional development to supervisors
and the chief of police police groomed
her for sexual exploitation
they colluded in using their authority
to systemic systematically disarm her
resistance and entrap her in degrading
an abusive sexual relationships even
sharing tips on the best ways to
manipulate and exploit her
the suit claims Hall who had a history
of mental illness felt trapped and in an
attempt to escape she nearly killed
herself Hall was fired in January after
word of the steamy sexcapades with five
other cops became public with those
officers also terminated from the
Department an interview during an
internal investigation the young cop
admitted she performed sex acts on duty
and on police to property and had a
threesome with one cop and his wife
he told the investigator that Hall told
the investigator that she got stupid and
got desperate in the midst of a divorce
inter Federal lawsuit Hall who was 24
when she first applied for the job on
the force in 2020 claims that she first
became sexually involved with Sergeant
Lewis Powell early last year
and um
and then Powell learned that uh he was
going that she was going through a
trying time in her relationship Sergeant
Powell positioned himself as a reliable
source of companionship and advice
regarding Miss Hall's career in her
marriage
and eventually Miss Hall gave in to
Sergeant Powell's requests for sexual
favors so this is what is
they're calling grooming
so she's not claiming that she was raped
you know this is some kind of violent
forcible rape that happened to her now
these are sexual relationships that she
consented to and that she decided to get
involved in as a grown adult woman
but now now uh after getting fired for
it she's she of course is the victim she
was being groomed
the couple questions immediately
come to mind one of them is that okay
now she's saying now we're being told by
her lawyers that she's mentally ill
incredibly vulnerable and susceptible
because she's so vulnerable and
susceptible mentally that she was able
to be quote groomed by five men
by the way you know uh there have been
other women who've worked jobs where
there may have been men who also worked
with them who were sexually attracted to
those women and would have liked to be
sexually involved with them and yet many
of these women are able to not end up
having sex with five of their co-workers
in fact most women are able to do that
but yet this woman she says is so
mentally ill and just susceptible and
and not in control of her own actions
that she had no choice she couldn't
control herself she was having sex all
the time with all the men that she
worked with
okay how did you become a cop then
why so what really tells the police
department hired a 24 year old mentally
ill woman
to become a police officer
and if you lived in that town you had to
call 911 emergency you might have had
this 24 year old mentally ill woman who
has no control of her own actions
according to her show up uh to you know
protect the defend and save you
it doesn't make me feel very safe I have
to say
but also it's interesting to me that
as we talked about the opening children
are being actually groomed
in drag shows and the rest of it but
we're not allowed to call that grooming
child being taken to a drag show not
allowed to call that grooming kids in uh
Elementary School
sitting down for classes being told
about gender identity and gender
fluidity and trans and all this stuff
not allowed to call that grooming
and yet a woman
has sex with five a grown adult woman
chooses to have sex with five men and
that we call grooming
now that's that's not grooming you are
an adult you are a grown adult
who made decisions
there's no grooming here
but of course you'll play the victim
card it's uh no surprise there and it
will probably work sad to say
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
Amy Says Matt Matt not having academic
credentials has actually helped me in
making my own voice heard I used to
never share my opinions because I
thought I wasn't intelligence or
intelligent or qualified enough to do so
man has helped me realize that you don't
need a degree to understand and defend
base of truth and you can do plenty of
research for things outside an academic
setting with this knowledge I've been
able to stand up for myself and my
beliefs more confidently than I ever
have before I deeply appreciate Matt and
all's ever since children
um
yeah this is one of the there are a lot
of disadvantages of living in the
so-called Information Age a lot of
disadvantages cultural disadvantages uh
and downsides to the internet but
it's here we have it so we might as well
exploit one of the upsides which is that
you have access to
um pretty much the sum total of human
knowledge you you carry around in your
pocket which means that you know we're
all capable of doing research and and
the learning things
doesn't mean that most people actually
use the technology for that purpose but
you can use it and you should
Cassie says Matt you should seriously
give some consideration to running for
office
uh
I someone said this to me yesterday and
I here's the way I would put it that I
would rather
I would rather be thrown into a volcano
than run for political office I would I
would that to me would be a more
appealing Prospect than running for
political office it's really the worst
thing in the world is to run for
political office
and there are a lot of people that would
also rather me be thrown into a volcano
than run for political office though
perhaps for different reasons
um there's nothing that's even remotely
appealing about it to me at this point
like if someone says that said that they
could snap their fingers and make me
president
I wouldn't want it I'd say no thank you
who'd want to be president
now if you could snap your fingers and
make me dictator over the entire Globe
then obviously I would take that but
president
no
um
seventh warlord says I used to work it
and that's one of the problems by the
way is that you you
to even want to run for higher office in
the first place
uh you you almost have to be psychotic
to begin with to to even want that
um and that's the Catch-22 that's
embedded in the system that most of the
people who would want to be president
shouldn't be president because they want
it
and uh so what you're looking for is
someone
it's someone who can somehow thread that
needle
where they're running for president and
they really are Mo they're not running
because they desperately want that
position for themselves it's most of the
people who run that's why they're doing
it because they desperately want it for
themselves
what you want someone who's running
because they actually feel called to it
they feel like it's they don't even
really want it but they feel like they
must because this is a vocation and
their calling it's what God has called
them to do that's that's what that's the
attitude you're looking for of course
every person running for office will
pretend that that's what they're
motivated by uh we're looking for the
very very small percentage of people who
actually are
motivated that way
um
and rarely do we find them
seventh warlord says I used to work at
Lowe's in the dog's welcome policy was a
hindrance to customers the dog waste and
the terrified customers were bad enough
but people took this domain that they
could bring in Bobcats reptiles and
monkeys
they bought the
Bobcats into uh into Lowe's Home
Improvement I've never seen that you
know I would actually prefer that if
we're going to do the thing where every
store and and every plane turns into a
zoo then I'd actually prefer to have
some in like you might as well be an
interesting animal if you're going to
bring your animals on board make it
something interesting not your golden
retriever I've seen a million of those
uh Margot says Matt I love you perhaps
they should be selective with what
student loans are forgiven I think
nurses plumbers electricians trade
workers should be forgiven this is a
compromise and might stimulate more
people to get into those fields I worked
really hard to become a nurse and I paid
every cent off my loan
yeah well that's
at least a better proposal than I've
heard from most of the people that are
calling for student loan forgiveness I
don't think that we should forgive any
student loans I think that if you made
this promise to pay back then you should
pay it back I think that you should
fulfill your own Financial Obligations
but it's very telling
that
the plan you described is not the plan
that any of these people are actually
calling for you know the ones that are
out on the steps of Supreme Court this
week uh ranting and raving about how
they want to do loan forgiveness
they're not saying well let's give let's
let's do this for blue collar workers
people in the trades and others let's do
it for them people that are actually
low-income middle class
they're not no they want it for they
might they might include the lower
income people but they want it for
themselves
what they what they especially want
actually is student loan forgiveness for
higher income earners because that's
that's them that includes them the ones
who are calling for this
which I think is very telling
all right finally uh okay this is not a
comment from uh on YouTube but I I did
speak it I have to play this clip
because I spoke at Stanford yesterday
and uh it was a good event and once
again there were no leftists who wanted
to get up in the Q a and actually really
argue with me but there was one moment
of an important conversation that
someone that we had uh I I was
challenged a little bit by someone who
got up and um had a question that had
nothing to do with gender ideology but
that was okay because it's still a very
important question and let's listen to
that
I want to ask you one fun question for
my sake and maybe people will laugh at
this but I know you're into UFOs and the
whole like possibility of aliens good
which to me I you know I think at this
point you're kind of excuse my language
but I think you're kind of stupid to not
believe in aliens now my question my
question to you is what what are your
thoughts on Bigfoot
how much time do we have because I could
go on for
eign
and when the aliens do land I think you
and I will be safe because we have
already stated our belief in the aliens
and we don't reject them the way all
these other people do
so they can be vaporized first and not
us but you have also I think
disrespected aliens by lumping them in
with Bigfoot I don't know why
it's like everyone thinks well uh it's
ghosts Bigfoot and Aliens as if they're
all the same kind of thing these are all
three different categories here and you
can have you you don't have to put them
all in the same basket
so my whole argument I told you I'd go
on Brothers my argument about aliens
hinges on the vastness of the universe
and the fact that there are trillions of
planets like hundreds of billions of
galaxies with 100 billions of stars and
and planets of trillions of planets and
so
the idea that there is no intelligent
life on any of them that the entire
universe is totally empty except for us
I find to be absurd but it works in the
opposite when it comes to Bigfoot
because now we're talking about what a
race of intelligent ape man Apes that
have lived like in the woods
in the woods in the back of your house
for centuries and no one has ever
got a good footage of them no one has
ever found a campsite no one's ever
found bones
a corpse nothing
so
let's look at it let him
thank you Matt I I do believe Bigfoot is
real
um I do I do think however I do think
however that they are separate in
separate categories but um anyways that
was a fun question uh for me to you
thank you for answering
those are fun questions important
question glad that we could talk about
that but I my wife saw that clip and uh
couldn't stop laughing about the fact
that while I was rambling about
ghosts and aliens of Bigfoot the the guy
was looking at his phone
um which I think that he was looking up
more Bigfoot facts because he was
thinking about arguing with me
uh but it's possible he just got bored
in the middle of the question that he
had the answer that I was giving to the
question no I think he was he was
he was looking up Bigfoot ammo I think
what happened is that I mentioned the
point which is true that no one's ever
we've never if there's a Bigfoot why
haven't there's never been any physical
evidence or anything like that burial
site
and I think he was Googling to see if he
could find evidence of such a thing and
he didn't see it and then he gave up so
I won that argument
Matt Walsh destroys Bigfoot believer
put that in the YouTube video it seems
that almost everywhere you turn the
world wants to make you woke but our
good friend Dennis Prager is on a
mission to make you wise instead and
thankfully Dennis Prager has created a
brand new series with daily wire plus
called the Masters program to do just
that we've had a long-standing
relationship with Dennis Prager and for
good reason he's been leading the charge
against stupidity for longer and I've
been alive with content like prageru's
five minute videos master's program
takes 40 years worth of wisdom and
experience from one of the most
influential conservative thinkers in
America today and it distills it all
down in a way that is relevant and
accessible episodes explore topics like
human nature basically good I think we
could say for certain that uh that I'm
obviously good but I can't speak for
everybody else the series always also
covers the consequences of secularism
which by the way are so dire needed two
episodes to explore it the first five
episodes of Prager use a master's
program are available is to stream right
now but only on daily wire plus so head
to dailywire.com subscribe to become a
member and watch prageru's Masters
program and more that's dailywire.com
subscribe today now let's get our daily
cancellation
foreign
along with many other people on social
media I recently became aware of a live
stream dating podcast on the whatever
YouTube channel whatever is the name of
the channel and this appeared on my
radar thanks to a truly delightful clip
where a young lady becomes enraged and
storms out of the room
after a man on the panel says that he
doesn't want to sleep with other men
this is the sort of statement expressing
a desire to not engage in homosexual
activity that counts as provocative
outrageous in our culture today I
thought the man handles the exchange
quite well let's take a look
Chase would you rather smash the hottest
trans woman in the world or the oldest
woman in the world honestly bro
the oldest woman in the world because
then I wouldn't be gay
what
you really just want me to just um
are you like Chase how dare you be
transphobic Yes actually do you mean yes
because if I had sex with a trans woman
I'd be having sex with a biological man
and I don't want to do that the question
is
I know
why don't you make it shut the up
because I have an opinion that differs
from yours
that's right I mean that's really hard
she's not it would technically be
homosexual
a trans woman is a biological man sue me
dude that's mean
what's up it's real it's true okay if
you've got you guys wanna
write any sexuality
I'm not allowed to say that I'm not
allowed to say that
woman
[Music]
God doesn't judge a Christian yeah yeah
you know you know what God said it said
he made the man I just told you I'm not
gay I'll pass on that thanks though
that's too far she says not wanting to
have sexual relations with a man is is
too far his Center his heterosexuality
is simply a bridge too far for this
young lady who along with her friend has
no choice but to flee the room and
disgust we must admit though that she
made a compelling argument to quote her
she says I don't even care if you're
doing this for like whatever but like
shut the f up actually
that's the kind of quote that would make
Mark Twain proud such incredible wit and
insight and and uh and all of it
communicated with such efficiency
now we can't blame her really for for
not being able to uh intelligently
articulate her objection to this man's
point of view on the subject it is an
unintelligible objection rooted in her
unthinking allegiance to gender ideology
which is also unintelligible
but the problem is that every clip that
circulates from this show which seems to
feature a different group of young women
and sometimes young men each episode
talking about their experiences in the
dating world uh every clip is is just as
mind-numbing and displays an equally
tenuous grasp on the English language so
here's one that attracted widespread
attention yesterday
um watch
I think like the biggest thing that like
annoys me in like the whole dating world
is like talking stages like that's so
annoying like the whole like
and just like the inconsistency in them
like I literally like hate that like so
much but I think that's like my biggest
thing is just like what specifically
just like the fact of just like you like
I don't know how to word this
like in like talking stages and it's
just like you're like labeled that and
it's like people like are considered
like you can't like you're just like
confused and like most of the time like
the girl get but gets like attached or
something and they like see it like it's
going to lead to a relationship and it's
always not and it's just like
that's like my biggest thing is like I
just hate the whole like how like
talking stages are so like normalized
like traditional dating does not exist
in this generation
now I'm informed by others who have
endured the clip and who had more time
on their hands that she used the word
like 27 times in the span of about 48
seconds haven't checked their math but
it sounds right
I suppose it's no wonder that the girl
doesn't like the talking stage given
that she seems to have so much trouble
talking
the unfortunate thing is that what she's
trying to express is actually important
it's uh it's an important Insight that
she is trying to trying to get across
it's just that it gets crushed under the
weight of a million likes
she's making the point or sort of
verbally gesturing towards the point
that the total banishment of labels and
traditions and Concepts like chivalry
from the dating scene
has left everyone feeling paralyzed and
Confused it means that most single
people end up in a kind of stasis a
limbo not knowing whether they're in a
relationship or what to do if they are
in one or what to call it
and nobody knows what to call anything
the fear of commitment that permeates
our culture the aggressive sort of
casualness of everything the insistence
on approaching all matters especially
matters relating to love and
relationships in a way that
diametrically opposes how our
grandparents approached it all of these
factors have made the dating scene not
simply difficult but effectively
non-existent people don't date they just
sort of float along on the cultural
current hoping that they bump into
another piece of debris before moving on
to the next there's no sense of purpose
or meaning certainly there's no clear
Direction
I think that's what she was trying to
say but instead she said like that like
it's all like so like you know like so
weird like whatever like
she doesn't fully understand her own
feelings on the subject nor does she
have the ability to communicate those
feelings uh she knows about 10 words
total and can only arrange and rearrange
them until she ends up with a sequence
that gets the closest to whatever half
form thought she wants to express now
it's not my intention to pick on this
poor girl she's uh she's she's not a
unique or extreme case
that's exactly why it's worth talking
about she is rather a typical product of
her generation
as nearly every older person has noted
Americans seem to be less articulate
with each passing generation and we're
now at a point where some people in gen
Z aren't even proficient in the one and
only language they know they're not
bilingual they're not even monolingual
they are non-lingual effectively
this is not the same as the familiar old
person complaint about youth slang right
that's not what this is the issue is not
slang
it isn't uh what words they've added to
the English language but rather what
words they've removed from it which is
most of them we are rapidly running out
of words as several Generations in a row
have taken part in this piecemeal
destruction of the English language
the Millennials complain about how gen Z
speaks just as Boomers did about
Millennials just as their parents did
about them and all of the complaints
were valid and only becoming more valid
as time goes on we are as a culture
progressively losing the ability to
express ourselves through language and
this is a rather significant problem
given that language is one of the
necessary cornerstones of any
functioning civilization
as I've observed in the past if you
really want to see just how much our
communication skills if not our
communication technology I mean our
technology is getting better our
communication technology is getting
better as our communication skills uh uh
you know are are falling apart but if
you really want to see how it has
deteriorated
all you have to do is go and uh go to
like a civil war Battlefield Museum
somewhere and read some of the letters
that average young men often with little
to no formal education
wrote home to their families to describe
their experiences
the National Park Service keeps an
online database actually I don't need to
go to a museum
and they have so a database of some
letters that were sent from Antietam
and before and after the the Battle of
Antietam so I'll read just the first
this is the first one if you go to this
website the first one that pops up on
the page is this it's from an infantry
private and this is what he writes
he rides on the 8th we struck up the
refrain of Maryland by Maryland and
camped in an apple orchard we went
hungry for six days not a morsel of
bread or meat had gone in our stomachs
and our menu consisted of apple and corn
we toasted we burned we stewed we boiled
we roasted these two together and singly
until there was not a man whose form had
not caved in you know had not a bad
attack of diarrhea our under clothes
were foul and hanging in strips our
socks worn out and half of the men were
barefooted many were lame and were sent
to the rear others of Sterner stuff
hobbled along and managed to keep up
while gangs from every company went off
in the surrounding country looking for
food many became ill from exposure and
starvation were left on the road the
ambulances were full and the whole route
was marked with a sick lame limping lot
that straggled to the farmhouses that
lie in the way and who in all cases
suckered and cared for them
okay so this is a normal guy not even
intending to write something that would
become a matter of the historical record
simply describing his experiences and he
does so in a way that is so elegant and
descriptive
that even if you didn't have any context
you would immediately know that it could
not have been written in this century
now imagine the girl from the podcast
trying to convey the same experience so
like we hadn't uh eaten and like so like
it was it was kind of like uh I don't
know how to say it I I guess like we
were hungry and honestly like it was
kind of gross and like literally we
didn't even have shoes
I probably already made the point but
there's one more letter written by a
private JD Hicks of the Pennsylvania
volunteers
um and he's trying to describe the
horror of finding a boy dead on the
battlefield
this is how he puts it
under the dark shade of a towering Oak
near the dunker Church lay the lifeless
form of a drummer boy apparently not
more than 17 years of age flax and hair
and eyes of blue and form of delicate
mold as I approached him I stooped down
and as I did so I perceived a bloody
Mark upon his forehead it showed where
the leaden messenger of death had
produced the womb that caused his death
his lips were compressed his eyes half
open a bright smile played upon his
countenance by his side lay his tenor
drum never to be tapped again
so this is an utterly haunting poignant
downright poetic account
dashed off in a letter from some young
guy
who couldn't have been much older than
the drummer boy in fact this the this
guy was 18 years old when he wrote that
this is how people used to communicate
okay and so and you could also find
plenty of Civil War letters that where
the spelling is horrendous and the uh
Punctuation is non-existent because
oftentimes again these these were uh
young men and boys that did have formal
schooling but even in those cases still
the language is there's a there's a wide
vocabulary that's evident and the
language is often very evocative and
Vivid and descriptive in a way that
people just aren't capable of anymore
that's how people used to communicate
vividly descriptively with words that
sufficiently captured the ideas they
wanted to convey and the experiences
that they wish to recount
we are a bunch of mumbling inarticulate
cows by comparison
why well for many reasons people don't
read books anymore and so they aren't
exposed to a wide vocabulary they spend
most of their time over stimulated by
screens and videos they communicate
mainly in Internet shorthand relying
heavily on little pictures emojis to
convey tone and emotion because they
don't know how to do it through actual
language when I complain about emojis
people always think that I'm joking and
it's the silly thing to complain about
but this is actually is damaging our
ability to communicate people don't you
hear people say well I got to use an
emoji because otherwise no one knows my
tone they don't know if I'm happy if
I've you know they don't know the tone
of that I'm that I'm using when I where
you're supposed to be able to
communicate that with language you're
supposed to be able to if you're writing
a message to someone use words that
convey whether you're happy or angry or
sad or whatever the fact that you need
the Emoji to do that shows a a troubling
limitation on our language abilities
and on top of all that and partially
because of it IQ scores have been
declining for years
that's how we got here
which on the plus side also gives us a
road map for getting out of the
situation
and how you get out of it is do the
reverse basically do the reversal that
of all that put down the screen pick up
a book
use words to communicate
real complete words and sentences
we'll probably never write as well as a
19th century Farm Boy on a Civil War
battlefield okay most of us will never
write that well
but we can improve
I hope we can at least
even that girl in the podcast even she
can improve
but for now because I have to cancel
someone at the end of this that is the
requirement of the segment but I must
say that she is sadly today canceled
that'll do it for the show today hope
you have a great day talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
John Bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less join me and
my co-host Georgia Howe for daily
coverage of all the biggest stories on
morning wire
[Music]